okay so in this video I want introduce
collagen okay so let's take a few notes
about it little tidbits that we should
be aware of that collagen is the most
abundant protein in the body okay
and so obviously it's important because
of that now it's a specifically
important because it's a major component
of connective tissue and just some
examples of connective tissue or working
that the tissues important skin bones
cartilage ligaments tendons of blood
vessel walls and also in the eye the
sclera and cornea okay now collagen is
specifically a fibrous protein and most
different types of proteins or globular
proteins but the most abundant protein
in the body collagen is a fibrous
protein and so it's long and broad like
or rope like some people say made up of
little fibers okay and it's important
because it provides structural support
for cells and tissues okay now there are
a bunch of different types of collagen
and I'm going to talk about some of them
here I think there are over 20 types
okay but I'm definitely not going to
talk about 20 different types of
collagen in this video I'm actually
going to talk about four of them so
let's go ahead and get into them
first up is type 1 now type 1 collagen
is kind of what people think of
classically when they think of collagen
and they think of this thick rope like
form which you can imagine if you if you
were to take I don't know three bits of
yarn or three pieces of string and you
kind of wrap them around each other and
twisted it really tightly you'd get
something that looks like collagen okay
and it's actually made of a as far as
type 1 it's a triple helix and we'll
talk more a little bit more about that
later
but and but it might be worth noting
that when it comes to type 1 College and
it's made up of three three little
polypeptide strands wrapped around each
other and with when it comes to those we
apply peptide strands two of they're
called alpha chains and two of them are
alpha one chains and then one of them is
an alpha 2 chain when it comes to type
one okay I'm not sure how important that
is but you might find that to be
of some sort of significance okay um
type 1 collagen is the strongest type of
collagen ok so it's pretty important
it's also the most abundant type of
collagen okay it makes up about 90% or
so of all of all collagen okay and it's
found in a bunch of places including the
bone skin tendons ligaments fascia teeth
cornea mature scars
mr. mature scar tissue and also the
blood vessel walls phone is probably
pretty important to remember as well as
tendons and ligaments and teeth and
cornea that that's that comes up here
and there so it's worth noting I also
it's important that when it comes to
scars here we think of mature scars so
it's not it's primarily exists when
scars are like done for me okay so
wooden scars are initially forming give
a different type of collagen we'll
mention then just a moment but mature
scar tissue has a lot of type one
collagen okay one way to remember this
that that bones are there is that type
one has bones in the word one is in bone
Oh any so type one bone okay also worth
noting like I said the cornea and mature
scar tissue okay cool
now there are some disorders associated
with type one collagen and we'll talk
more about them later but ehlers-danlos
syndrome or abs as well as osteogenesis
imperfecta
oh I or also known as brittle bone
disease we'll talk a little bit more
about that later in the series okay so
that's basically it for type one okay
next up type two
you